[Música]
7 hace cinco años 195 países concretaban
juntos el primer acuerdo universal sobre
el clima el acuerdo de parís países
desarrollados países pobres víctimas o
contribuidores todos juntos en la lucha
contra el calentamiento global
en esa época todo lo llevaba a cabo
francia y en particular en la sombra
había una mujer a menudo en tenis
nuestra invitada de hoy lawrence
toubiana antigua negociadora en jefe de
francia y arquitecta de este acuerdo
lawrence estudian muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros cinco años después
llegó por supuesto el momento del
balance es injusto afirmar que se
permitió poco en parís aparece la que es
muy insuficiente ante el reto y que
desde entonces se ha hecho poco de
manera concreta
efe
y yo haría un juicio un poco más
matizado muchas gracias por invitarme a
ser parte de esta retrospectiva en
realidad en parís se decidieron tres
cosas muy importantes por un lado se
fijaría un objetivo global ambicioso
para mantener las temperaturas por
debajo de los dos grados de ser posible
no más de un grado y medio en relación
con la época preindustrial y para eso es
necesario alcanzar cero emisiones netas
en 2050 las emisiones deben haberse
reducido de manera considerable sin
contar por supuesto la capacidad de la
naturaleza para capturar carbono ese es
el objetivo más ambicioso
[Música]
el segundo objetivo y la segunda
obligación para los países es presentar
planes climáticos cada cinco años
reevaluando los cada vez y el tercero es
por supuesto revisarse los unos a los
otros algo que se hace y que haya en
particular estrategias a largo plazo
para ser coherentes con este objetivo de
parís
y eso fue lo que se decidió en parís lo
que significa que los planes climáticos
propuestos en 2015 eran borradores y que
los planes climáticos definitivos los
que deben ser realmente coherentes con
el objetivo de 2050 con el objetivo de
mantenerse por debajo de los dos grados
deben estar listos este año estaban
previstos para este año oa más tardar el
próximo año porque a causa de la crisis
de kobe la conferencia de las partes que
debían evaluar esos planes climáticos
fue pospuesta para el próximo año desde
este punto de vista estamos esperando
esos nuevos anuncios los verdaderos
anuncios
es decir los que pondrán en marcha el
acuerdo de parís porque en realidad el
acuerdo de parís empieza a partir del
2020 incluso aunque se haya negociado
hace cinco años porque había otras cosas
en marcha en particular el protocolo de
kioto que ya está terminado
un autista con su visión europa aumentó
su contribución espero que ahora vayamos
hacia una reducción del 55 en 2030 ahora
vimos la china en septiembre pasado
proponer un objetivo mucho más ambicioso
del que tenía anteriormente en
particular y gracia cero emisiones netas
en 2060 visitamos y luego está eeuu que
regresa al juego está japón-corea del
sur hay una nueva movilización pero han
pasado muchas cosas en 5 años aunque es
posible que volvamos sobre este tema en
unos instantes
justamente usted habla sobre esta
carrera por la neutralidad de carbón ya
ha habido muchos anuncios en la última
semana
algunos lo ven como una buena noticia
otros consideran que es una manera de
fijar objetivos muy largo plazo usted
habla de 2050 260 eso es dentro de
muchísimo tiempo
en objetivos a muy largo plazo para
ocultar en realidad el vacío de las
acciones a corto plazo
y eso hay que corregirlo por supuesto
que si sólo hubiera anuncios a 2050 o
2060 no sería algo serio es necesario
que haya planes precisos que incluyan
medidas inmediatas que deben tomarse en
esos cinco años para alcanzar esa
neutralidad de carbono en 2050 o en 2060
para un país grande como china cuyas
emisiones son muy altas
y por supuesto todo se juega sobre la
credibilidad de los planes por eso es
muy importante lo que los países decidan
para 2030 es decir cuál será su plan
climático definitivo y que digan cómo lo
van a lograr no es simplemente una cifra
se trata de las medidas
y cuando uno mira por ejemplo el
compromiso europeo se ve como europa
para alcanzar una reducción del 55 por
ciento o la neutralidad de carbono para
2050 habiendo por ejemplo acelerado la
electrificación del transporte exilió
con el plan hacia 2030 o 2035 es no
tener más automóviles nuevos que estén
construidos con un motor de combustión
es decir tener automóviles eléctricos
la renovación de los edificios
formación de la agricultura la
transformación de la industria la
conformación eléctrica
europa tiene un plan bastante claro
preciso que estará finalizando en el
primer semestre de 2021 pero los países
también
mire por ejemplo reino unido- que
anunció el final de la venta de
vehículos con motor de gasolina para
2030 y también anunció un aumento en su
ambición de reducir un 68 por ciento
para 2030 en relación con 1990 hay
muchos otros países también nueva
zelanda actualmente japón y corea del
sur también están haciendo propuestas
estamos en plena removilización política
es verdad que la salida de eeuu del
acuerdo de parís por champ le puso
evidentemente un freno a esta
movilización política
pero desde entonces yo diría que con el
esfuerzo europeo que realmente le ha
devuelto la energía política ahora con
china y con la nueva administración
estadounidense estamos en un contexto
completamente nuevo
justamente usted lo acaba de mencionar
en eeuu se entra en esta nueva era la
del presidente electo joe baile con un
representante especial para el clima
john kerry que usted conoce bien él
estuvo en parís en 2015 es posible decir
que eeuu regresa al buen camino después
de cuatro años de negación climática que
se debe esperar concretamente de su
regreso al acuerdo nuevo aire no
y muchas cosas de nuevo creo que el
liderazgo europeo está establecido y
está establecido por la credibilidad del
compromiso y sobre todo por la
credibilidad política que lo acompaña
china también decidió seguirlo y en eeuu
en el plan de bailén fue realmente
admirable ver que entre las cuatro
prioridades del candidato a la
presidencia estadounidense el clima
estaba ahí era parte de las cuatro
prioridades
el plan by the end que por supuesto
estará bajo presión por los problemas de
mayoría en el senado es tener una
electricidad cero carbono en 2035
acelerar la electrificación del
transporte y llegar a cero emisiones
netas para 2050 y suscriptos son
entonces cosas muy cercanas a lo que
quiere hacer la unión europea
entre china europa y eeuu está de todas
maneras lo esencial los grandes actores
de la economía mundial que se dirigen
hacia cero emisiones netas y actualmente
hay que esperar por supuesto que eeuu de
china de medidas inmediatas como lo hizo
europa
utilización pero hay una re movilización
política y evidentemente esto tendrá un
impacto internacional considerable en
particular frente a países como brasil o
australia que estaban realmente
atrasados y que de cierta manera por
seguir action no querían acentuar sus
acciones
[Música]
me gustaría que habláramos un poco más
del contexto tan especial que estamos
atravesando en este momento y esta
pandemia que en apariencia disminuye la
velocidad de nuestras ambiciones de
vídeo 2 y sobre estos planes de
reactivación que se perfilan esta vez lo
sabemos con verdaderas decisiones
políticas y ecológicas por tomar en qué
energías invertir a los países de
sectores invertirán dinero los estados
no hay en eso un verdadero cambio es
ahora
así es yo misma estaba preocupada cuando
se desató la crisis del cob y de en
particular cuando ocurrió en nuestro
país en europa y por supuesto temía que
los compromisos europeos tan ambiciosos
fueran dejados de lado pero no ocurrió
así y es verdad usted tiene razón
es un momento pendular porque todas esas
inversiones públicas considerables esos
cientos de miles de millones que están
sobre la mesa actualmente en europa en
eeuu en otros lugares para responder
ante la crisis efectivamente según las
decisiones que se tomen acelerarán lo
que se debe hacer si la acción hacia la
descarbonización de las economías hacia
la electrificación del transporte y la
renovación de los edificios o incluso la
transformación de la agricultura o la
industria son en efecto muchas
decisiones los recursos públicos no son
eternos no tendremos miles y miles de
millones de inversiones públicas
evidentemente habrá una movilización de
finanzas privadas porque por supuesto
son sectores muy prometedores también
desde el punto de vista del desarrollo
económico es verdad de este año 2020 el
2021 la salida de la crisis por el
commit de la crisis económica y social
es realmente un momento pendular en la
acción sobre el cambio climático y hoy
soy más optimista de lo que era hace 8
meses usted es optimista es una pregunta
muy simple que le deben hacer con
frecuencia cree que sea posible llegar a
limitar este calentamiento global por
debajo de los 2 grados se puede lograr
según un estudio muy reciente del clima
jackson tracker un organismo
independiente que trata de medir los
impactos de las contaminaciones las
emisiones de los compromisos que se
toman evidentemente depende de que los
países mantengan sus compromisos
antes de parís los índices de aumento
del clima las tendencias nos llevaban
hacia un aumento de temperatura de entre
4 y 5 grados en relación con el período
preindustrial los primeros planes los
borradores lo que yo llamo borradores de
lo que se presentó en parís nos llevaban
a grandes rasgos hacia los 3 grados de
calentamiento global
lo que está hoy en día sobre la mesa
desde el verano y desde el mes de
septiembre nos lleva a los dos grados
es necesario ir todavía más allá es
necesario que en 2021 en glasgow el
conjunto de los países presenten
contribuciones más ambiciosas vamos por
buen camino con dos condiciones así que
los países sean serios y hagan lo que
dicen
y de cierta manera le corresponde a
todas las sociedades ya todos los
ciudadanos obligar a los gobiernos a
hacerlo lee su tuit y lugar sí y al
mismo tiempo que efectivamente en
glasgow los actores económicos las
instituciones financieras las
autoridades locales porque no son sólo
los gobiernos es el conjunto del sistema
económico y político se tomen en serio
el clima justicia
y creo que ahí tenemos una ventana de
posibilidad por supuesto se va a cerrar
entonces hasta finales de 2021 para
hacer esos compromisos y lograr una
convergencia de compromisos y acciones
entre las empresas los alcaldes de las
grandes ciudades los presidentes de las
regiones o de los estados y los
gobiernos
pero creo que hoy en día después de un
periodo realmente difícil de todas
maneras muy relacionado con el
posicionamiento de eeuu creo que de
nuevo tenemos una ventana para poder
actuar vamos por el buen camino nos
despedimos con sus palabras
definitivamente optimistas
muchas gracias luego estudian por haber
estado con nosotros en france24 quédense
con nosotros nos vemos en breve para más
información
[Música]